new details have emerged about the
tragic death of friend star Matthew
Perry and it's only made the loss of
this beloved actor even more
heartbreaking on October 28th the
entertainment industry lost one of its
most beloved television stars Matthew
Perry best known for playing Chan La
Bing on Friends was found deceased in
his home at the age of 54 he was found
unresponsive in a hot tub at his home
where he was declared dead at the scene
from an apparent drowning TMZ is now
reported on the contributing factors to
his death from the Los Angeles County
Medical examiner's Office the toxicology
report States per died from quote the
acute effects of ketamine ketamine is a
substance often used for pain management
as well as a treatment of certain mental
health issues TMZ reports that Perry had
been receiving ketamine therapy for
depression and anxiety however his last
ketamine infusion therapy occurred a
week and a half prior to his passing
therefore it was determined the ketamine
in his system quote could not be from
that infusion therapy since ketamine's
half life is 3 to 4 hours or less the
medical examiner also stated how the
ketamine in the actus system resulted in
quote both cardiovascular
overstimulation and respiratory
depression additional factors in the
actor's death include drowning coronary
artery disease and borine effects borine
is a prescription medicine given to
individuals suffering from opioid
addiction while they were not
contributing factors to his death the
report also indicates Matthew Perry had
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease as
well as diabetes Perry was open about
his struggles with addiction throughout
his life the medical examiner determined
the actor was sober for 19 months before
he died and it was previously reported
that Matthew Perry did not have fenil or
meth in his system at his time of death
in 2022 while promoting his Memoir Perry
wrote about how he wanted to use his
experience with addiction as an Avenue
to help others going through similar
struggles
because I was on friends more people
will listen to me so I've got to take
advantage of that I've got to help as
many people as I can Perry told people
in an interview how much he valued his
sobriety everything starts with sobriety
because if you don't have sobriety
you're going to lose everything that you
put in front of it so my sobriety is
right up there in the time since his
death there's been an outpouring of
support from fans towards Perry's family
and friends with his friends co-stars
releasing a statement honoring their
friend if you or anyone you know needs
help with addiction issues help is
available visit the Substance Abuse and
Mental Health Services Administration
website or contact samire National
helpline at 1 1800 662 help
[Music]